[Musique]
connaissez-vous la pachamama la
pachamama c'est une déesse de la culture
inca
ma mère est péruvienne donc j'ai été
bercé par cette légende mama ça veut
dire mr mère nourricière celle qui prend
soin pas de chat c'est la terre le sol
le monde jusqu'aux cosmos pour les incas
il n'y a pas de différence entre le
temps et l'espace l'espace-temps
s'appelle patch à la pachamama c'est
celle qui prend soin de tous de tout le
vivant et de l'espace temps cette
légende m'a vraiment touché petit et je
me suis toujours sentie l'héritière en
fait de cette culture alors 20 ans plus
tard je suis allé sur les traces de mes
origines ou pelvoux et là il s'est passé
quelque chose
j'ai rencontré les descendants de mes
ancêtres et cette femme formidable
à qui on donne plus d'âge qui m'a parlé
dans sa langue qui était même pas de
l'espagnol puisque elle parlait qui
choix j'ai pas compris ce qu'elle m'a
dit mais quelque chose et passer un
message en tout cas de puissant
peut-être que c'était la pachamama qui
avait attrapé une tenue et qui était
venu me parler
cette culture elle est formidable
on voit un petit peu encore les vestiges
de ce qu'étaient les incas ils ont
construit des forteresses à 2500 mètres
d'altitude ils ont trouvé des solutions
pour produire de la nourriture dans ces
conditions extrêmes
et là il ya quelque chose qui a
travaillé en moi j'ai trouvé ça
formidable cette résilience en fait
cette façon trouver des solutions est de
réussir à nourrir tout le monde
il avait un système très intéressant de
vie
qu'on pourrait assimiler à la
permaculture petit on m'appelait
pocahontas poc pour les intimes et du
coup quand j'étais au pérou il ya une
chanson qui m'est revenue la chanson du
dessin animé pocahontas qui vous
connaissez peut-être l'air du vent mais
la terre n'est que poussière dans que
l'homme ignore comment il peut peindre
mille couleurs
l'air du vent c'est une superbe
invitation en fait à observer la nature
autrement réussir à peindre de mille
couleurs l'air du vent victor victor
hugo disait il est triste de penser que
la nature nous parle mais que l'homme
n'écoute pas là aussi les sens devrait
être développé pouvoir voir un peu toute
la beauté la merveille qu'est la nature
en réalité moi je suis une urbaine j'ai
vécu à la ville je suis né à côté de
paris
j'ai pas été dans une culture paysanne
de la terre pourtant ça a toujours
évoqué quelque chose d'important pour
moi et donc à ce retour du pérou j'ai
décidé de changer de vie je travaillais
dans l'immobilier à paris sur les champs
elysées j'ai démissionné et je suis
parti en normandie créer ma propre ferme
alors c'est une aventure quand on n'est
ni ma comme moi qu'est ce que c'est une
emma c'est une non issus du milieu
agricole
mais on y arrive et puis la pachamama
elle nous enseigne des choses
importantes sortir du schéma pyramidal
dans lequel on est aujourd'hui qu'ils
consomment
la terre et aller vers quelque chose de
circulaire où on est tous en harmonie ça
c'est une très bonne leçon très
importante de la pachamama
et aussi qu'il n'y a pas de plan b nous
devons réduire notre empreinte sur terre
si nous voulons laisser une chance aux
générations futures de voir la beauté de
la nature
il n'y a pas de planète b mais notre
planète bleue
elle est merveilleuse donc ça c'est le
message de ban ki moon et très récemment
aussi nicolas hulot et je pense que
beaucoup de gens comme moi se pose des
questions
eh bien j'ai trouvé une solution ça
s'appelle la permaculture
alors qu'est ce que c'est que la
permaculture c'est un mode de vie en
fait avec des pétales
on va s'occuper de tout notre quotidien
et réduire notre empreinte être
résilient et développer la vie partager
les ressources équitablement et prendre
soin de l'humain donc vous allez pouvoir
faire le pétale par exemple de l'habitat
avec de l'epo construction de la
gouvernance en essayant de faire les
choses plus en rond quand pyramide de
l'éducation de vos enfants
en allant vers d éducation alternative
et bien sûr l'agriculture en allant vers
l'agroécologie donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui m'a beaucoup inspiré dans le
cadre de la ferme où on a pu mettre en
pratique la magie de la nature
imaginez vous est ce qu'il ya un
meilleur placement que la nature vous
plantez un haricot
il est pas magique à un haricot normal
vous aurez pu le taiso récolter 100
c'est quand même merveilleux et donc
tout c'est toutes ces choses qu'on a
pratiqué à la ferme
ça a été beaucoup d'erreurs mais c'était
pas des échecs
si on en tire une leçon et de toutes ces
expériences
j'en ai écrit un livre à destination des
gens comme moi lenny ma non issus du
milieu agricole
parce qu'on est de plus en plus nombreux
à vouloir ce retour à la terre et à
participer au changement
donc c'est ce mouvement que je suis dont
je suis venu vous parler aujourd'hui
aussi de ce retour à la terre de tous
ces jeunes qu'ils empruntent le chemin
de la nature et qui suivent les
enseignements finalement de la
permaculture et de la pachamama alors
oui
c'est pas facile tous les jours on va
pas vous mentir c'est un métier
difficile surtout quand on a travaillé
dans des bureaux
la terre est basse très basse on a mal
au dos on a les ongles sales mais
qu'est-ce qu'on dort bien comme une
souche et on a vraiment eu l'impression
de faire quelque chose de notre journée
en fait
et puis cette terre l exigeante mais
elle nous soigne elle nous connecte au
moment présent et les plantes qui
poussent dans notre ferme sont là aussi
pour nous aider un rhume on prend du
temps la sauge quand on a mal au ventre
etc
la nature est bien faite alors j'avais à
coeur bien sûr pour retrouver mes
racines un cas d'aller vers la diversité
les pleins de variétés en fait parce
qu'aujourd'hui on trouve trois variétés
de tomates en supermarché mais il en
existe des milliers au pérou ils ont
mille variétés de tomates mille variétés
de pommes de terre
bon alors on ne va pas tout cultiver on
en a des cultiver quand même beaucoup et
c'est ça qui est beau ses couleurs ses
goûts ses saveurs
cette fraîcheur on retrouve plus
forcément dans les produits qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui dans les contenants les
commerces les prendre soin de la terre
il ya quelques règles fondamentales en
agroécologie et on a surtout un allié
extraordinaire c'est le ver de terre
plus vous avez de vers de terre
plus votre terre à les riches il ya
donnera de bons légumes et pour faire
venir les vers de terre on prend soin de
la vie
on plante des arbres on sème des engrais
verts on amène de l'amendement du fumier
on ne retourne pas le sol
on ne touche plus au sol les vers de
terre fonctionne mieux que les tracteurs
ils ne fonctionnent pas aux énergies
fossiles
ils travaillent bénévolement ils ne
prennent pas de vacances alors la plus
grande galère pour nous la plus grande
difficulté qu'on a dans nos métiers
c'est qu'on venait frapper de plein
fouet déjà dès maintenant par le
réchauffement climatique le
bouleversement climatique des neiges
alors qu'on les attend plus des gels
tardifs qui dure trois jours
des pluies torrentielles la sécheresse
même en normandie
imaginez-vous on a vu on a vu des
sécheresses incroyable donc il faut
prendre les choses avec philosophie et
tu n'es pas philosophe qui veut pour
être un vrai philosophe il faut laisser
plus voir quand il pleut la paysannerie
vous rentrez philosophe tout ce
mouvement est en train de prendre de
l'ampleur en france
et tant mieux parce qu'on est en train
de prouver qu'on peut cultiver sans
chimie avec du bon sens en développant
le lien les liens humains et en
satisfaisant en fait tout le monde
là on voit les clients de la map qui
viennent chercher les légumes
il ya de la vie qui revient dans les
villages grâce à nos fermes et la
solidarité aussi
on en a besoin moi je travaille
maintenant pour une association qui
s'appelle ferme d'avenir et qui a fait
le tour de la france
l'année dernière un tour de france en
tout cas des initiatives agro écologique
on a visité 220 ferme et toutes ces
fermes ont ça en commun d'être en
agroécologie de s'inspirer de la
permaculture de la nature pour faire
mieux et je pense là à tous ces visages
que j'ai croisés à laurianne et charles
avec leur élevage de cochons à ville
marie est scellé guide spirituel au
surfeur maraîchers béni coup à l'éco
lieu du 100ème nom qui réinvente un
vivre ensemble tous et toutes ces
personnes sont en train de réinventer un
monde meilleur pour demain tous nous
nous battons pour que le la terre soit
plus belle et qu'il ait plus de liens en
harmonie avec la nature
alors maintenant j'ai la dernière petite
graine spéciale qui est en train de
grandir en moi à qui je vais transmettre
tout ça à qui je vais apprendre à
planter et à qui je vais montrer
pocahontas pour l'inspirer
et je vous rejoins je vous invite tous
en fête à rejoindre cette ronde de la
permaculture est à inventer avec nous le
monde de demain
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]